all right a few things to sort of get
caught up on here as we still are seeing
2020's two results come in and so many
other different things want to get a
couple of ketchups uh uh going here
we have made it abundantly clear how
much is at stake
how much was at stake in 2022 and how it
relates to so much being at stake in
2024. just to I feel like I'm quoting
Rachel Maddow here to give you some of
the Contours and texture of really what
may happen in 2024 depending on the path
forward there's a stunning new article
in Rolling Stone from Ryan bort and
azawin subsang
about Donald Trump looking for ways to
imprison journalists jail reporters if
he is indeed able to retake the White
House Trump keeps musing about
journalists being raped in prison and
he's not joking they write
a knowledgeable Source tells Rolling
Stone that the former president has
wondered how he might be able to jail
reporters if he takes the White House
which of course is absolutely and
completely chilling you might remember
in fact I think we even have a clip here
Donald Trump telling these sorts of
stories about prison rape during Israel
from the Supreme Court first time it's
ever happened is just unbelievable but
you get the information very easily you
tell the reporter who is it And the
reporter will either tell you or not and
if the reporter doesn't want to tell you
it's bye-bye
the Reporter Goes to Jail and when the
reporter learns that he's going to be
married in two days to a certain
prisoner that's extremely strong tough
and mean
he will say you know he or she you know
I think I'm going to give you the
information here's the leaker get me the
hell out of here yeah so that is a joke
about prison rape but it doesn't stop
there and this isn't merely idle uh the
article explains this year as Trump has
privately strategized about what a
second term would look like he's begun
occasionally soliciting ideas from
conservative allies for how the U.S
government and justice department could
go about turning his desires for
brutally imprisoning significant numbers
of reporters into reality several months
ago the former president briefly asked a
small gathering of allies and at least
one of his lawyers what would have to be
done to make that Vision a norm he said
other countries do it the implication
being why not here now you know as the
article points out Trump for a long time
has sort of idolized or at least looked
favorably upon the authoritarian states
that do exactly that type of thing North
Korea as the article says does not
tolerate free expression China and
Russia are well known for jailing
journalists or Bond the Trump endorsed
autocrat of Hungary has been targeting
reporters
etc etc Trump has also been praising she
in China for the so-called quick trials
with a nearly hundred percent conviction
of drug dealers in China followed by the
death penalty this is why he's so taken
with these sorts of folks and I here's
my desire you know we've done the
exercise in 2016 where many of us said
this is not an academic or theoretical
distinction
when you consider the Supreme Court
the attack on press Liberties all of
these things
Hillary Clinton for four years and
Donald Trump for four years could not
have been more different and all those
people who said let's shake it up let's
just see what happens if it's not Bernie
it's Trump then that's fine or I don't
see any real difference between Hillary
and Trump and I'll stay home or all the
people that were saying these things
we effed around and found out maybe it
would be the way to say it and at this
point we need to believe the things
Trump says he would like to be able to
imprison journalists when they say or
write things he doesn't like he's
talking about it with allies and he's
talking about it with lawyers
let's not
explore or find out what will happen and
that's why as I said yesterday this
Trump descended stuff I could not care
less about these individuals as people
my concern is how can they most damage
themselves and their party
such that none of them will win in 2024
and we will probably find that out
relatively soon
if you have a friend or loved one who is
passionate about the environment here is
a perfect holiday gift our sponsor
established titles is a project that
lets you ceremonially purchase as little
as one square foot of dedicated land in
edelston Scotland so that you can call
yourself a lord or a lady like the
historic Scottish tradition some people
even change their plane tickets or
credit cards to include Lord or lady
your title pack comes with an official
certificate you can see exactly where
your plot of land is located it makes a
perfect last minute gift but most
importantly established titles plants
one free tree for every plot of land
sold established titles does really good
work all over the world with
reforestation organizations like one
tree planted and trees for the future so
you'll have a great laugh whether you're
Scottish or not I'm not but you're
giving the gift gift of reforestation to
fight climate change if you use my link
you'll get 10 percent off and your plot
of land will be right next to mine you
can see it on a map go to established
titles.com Pacman and use the code
Pacman for an extra 10 off on top of
their Black Friday deal the link is down
below